[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es eine typisch türkisches
rezept ich werde mich barrick machen
barry gibt's natürlich auch in anderen
ländern in bosnien zum beispiel da kenne
ich von meiner freundin und heute werde
ich den youth pipe selber machen so wie
ich ihn von meiner mama kenne und auch
da gibt es wirklich ganz ganz viele
verschiedene arten wie man ihn
zubereiten kann
die meistens nämlich so dass in den teig
keine hefe mit rein kommt aber ich finde
es traurig ist dann immer so ein
bisschen zu hart deswegen gebe ich ein
bisschen hilfe mit rein damit einfach
besser lockerer wird aber dennoch
knusprig wird
ich zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten für
den teig für den teig brauche ich ein
kilo mehl jeweils einen teelöffel zucker
und trockenhefe eineinhalb teelöffel
salz jeweils 300 milliliter milch und
wasser und 40 milliliter und ihr könnt
dieses rezept übrigens auch ganz einfach
vegan machen indem ihr die milch durch
wasser austauscht und später bei der
füllung und beim bestreichen sage ich
euch auch noch mal ich nehme jetzt erst
einmal hefe und zucker und gibt es in
der küchenmaschine also meine mama nicht
werden denn früher den teig immer mit
der hand geknetet und haben da immer
zwei drei kilo gemacht aber mittlerweile
geht natürlich bisschen einfacher wenn
man das so macht aber natürlich könnt
ihr noch mit der hand verkneten
da kommt jetzt mehr rein aber noch nicht
alles also ein bisschen lasse ich immer
gerne übrig dann auch die milch und das
öl nun der teig wird jetzt auch mal
schön geknetet und sobald es sich dann
zu einem teig verbunden hat gebe ich das
restliche mir langsam mit dazu
der teig ist jetzt schön geschmeidig
verknetet und im türkischen sackmann er
soll es so weit sein wie das ohrläppchen
colak mm gibt es jetzt auch so schön
weit ist stehen alle hinter der kamera
machen so und den lasse ich jetzt
erstmal eine halbe stunde aufgeben so
kann ein bisschen ausruhen und ich habe
später es an bitten einfacher in
ausrollen und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich jetzt schon mal die füllung
vorbereiten und zeigt euch da die
zutaten
hier steht jetzt noch die restlichen
zutaten ich brauche zwei esslöffel
sonnenblumenöl eine große knoblauchzehe
eine zwiebel essig salz pfeffer und
chili ein kilo baby spinat zum
bestreichen der juka blätter brauche ich
150 milliliter sonnenblumenöl zum
bestreichen der barrick zwei esslöffel
sonnenblumenöl und zwei esslöffel
joghurt und zum bestreuen schwarzkümmel
zwiebel und knoblauch habe ich bereits
geschält und verein gehört würde ich
doch ich dachte ihr wisst wahrscheinlich
wie das geht
wie gehts nämlich sonnenblumenöl und
gibt es bereits in den heißen topf und
da kommen jetzt die zwiebeln und
knoblauch würzen dazu und werden kurz
angebraten
luft
sobald die sieben leicht farbe bekommen
haben
kommt jetzt der spieler aber so
standardspruch sieht jetzt macht viel
aus aber es wird gleich ganz ganz wenig
und bete spinat muss man nicht klein
schneiden aber falls ihr den großen
spieler habt könnt ihr den vorher noch
ein bisschen schneiden und da passiert
auch gleich sieben kilo war
der spinat ist jetzt komplett
eingefallen und jetzt kann ich in würzen
mit salz pfeffer und etwas chili wenn
ihr mögt und ich habe es hier nicht das
ganze kino spieler hat mittring denn wer
hat bloß auf einem schiff deswegen ist
hier ein bisschen spinat drin der orange
eine mango eiswürfel und ein großes
stück ingwer und natürlich bitter wasser
man muss jetzt nochmals richtig gesundes
honecker richtig schönes großes stück
ingwer mal kurz auf der spieler der teig
ist ausgeruht die füllung ist bereits
abgekühlt und jetzt kann ich den teig
erstmal portionieren
ich werde jetzt ein teil in 16
gleichmäßiges stücke
und die form ist jeweils zu einer kugel
nämlich eine teig kugel und drückt sie
leicht flach
es kommt nämlich das spaßige teil
unternehmen jetzt ein oxer war dass ich
so ein typischer aus und starb mein papa
hat meine mama auch mal einen gemacht
aus dem wesen stehen also neue betten
steht das geht auch mit dem kann man
eben die teige richtig dünn ausrollen es
jetzt erstmal so dünn gemacht so etwa
teller groß würde ich jetzt nicht gerade
filmen würde ich den teig auf diese holz
arbeitsplatte aus rollen weil ich da
einfach ein bisschen mehr platz hat und
hier rechts und links nicht an stufe
kommt immer wieder ein bisschen mehr
rein und dann rolle ich den teig drum
herum und kann jetzt von der mitte nach
außen immer die hände so ein bisschen
abstreiten
also den teig nach außen streichen
jetzt ist es groß genug
und zwar so dass man wirklich
durchgucken kann also die ewv kompletter
sollten sehr dünn werden
jetzt nehme ich das öl und es ist auch
ganz wichtig dass es jetzt hier innen
ratten kommt damit das jufa barack
einfach schön knusprig wird und auch
nicht zu trocken
was kommt jetzt hier hinein
teilt es auch immer ganz gerne in dem
ich die blätter auf und zuklappen
die füllung und die platze ich jetzt
hier außen am rand und da kann man jetzt
entweder die spiegelung nehmen einfach
nur käse füllung eine kartoffel fülle
oder auch eine hackfleisch von zb
hier in die mitte kommt jetzt ein strick
als einmal durchschneiden nichts von
außen nach innen zu zusammenrollen
jetzt soll ich das erste break so
zusammen und machen eine schnecke drauf
diese schnecke sitze ich jetzt hier auf
ein backblech dann nämlich jetzt ein
präpariertes backblech mit löchern also
drin damit einfach schön knusprig backen
ihr könnt jetzt entweder viele einzelnen
schnecken machen oder eine große
schnecken nudel dafür die schnecke jetzt
auseinander schneiden polizeistreifen
und jetzt einfach immer wieder um die
schnecke herumlägen
bei mir haben jetzt etwa fünf von diesen
kugeln auf einem blech gepasst und dann
nehmen da einfach das nächste und jetzt
habe ich hier die joghurt öl mischung
und verhöre sehen und damit bestreichen
jetzt das doric und fallt ihr das ganze
wega machen wollt könnt ihr jetzt hier
einfach das den joghurt weglassen und
nur mit öl bestreichen
wer möchte kann das büro jetzt noch mit
etwas schwarzkümmel bestreuen oder zu
müssen auch mit sesam oder mit beidem
und die restlichen die ich jetzt machen
werde wenn ich auch mit spinat führen
und teilweise auch mit käse und die
barrick werden jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad etwa 20 bis 25
minuten gebacken
perry ist jetzt fertig und ich habs
jetzt fünf minuten etwa abkühlen lassen
sich nicht beschwert dass ich wieder zu
heiß ich glaube es gab selten mal ein
video wie so hunderte wie heute als
minister
ich kann mich gar nicht erinnern
wirklich und ich glaube ich kann das
könnte nach gar nicht schmecken trotzdem
lieben also nicht ich möchte jetzt nicht
ein weil guttenberg kritisiert aber ich
habe echt mordshunger alle richtig und
wikis den seelen so gut und spinat ist
ja sowieso unser liebling ist übrigens
noch richtig leckeren kartoffel füllung
machen oder kajak oder mit holz zu tun
ist möglich
wundervoll von außen habt ihr gehört
richtig schön knusprig und diese
einzelnen teigschichten also es lohnt
sich wirklich des berichts zu machen man
kann natürlich auch yoga selber also
keiner kaufen ja aber es schmeckt nicht
so wie das hier und jetzt mal trocken
und jetzt würde ich doch etwas perfekt
bei schächte perfekt wirken wenn diesen
käse machen wir das mit der sahne wo du
machst uns und ich fragen habe ich ja
mal ein video dazu gemacht es war diese
baguette oder dieses französische brot
und käse djp.at unten der videobox und
das mit dem käse zusammen wir waren sind
deshalb ist identisch oder noch einen
tee dazu unten perfekte probieren
also dieses alles ist ein bisschen ein
bisschen weichen drin und außen trotzdem
cross oder das problem muss mal und das
im ofen ist noch mit käse und eine
richtig heiße 190 grad
aber ich muss sagen das hast du gemerkt
wie schmeckt einfach wirklich echt
wirklich lecker also ich will das alles
ist
wir wollen alle was davon essen
jedenfalls falls jetzt auch lust auf
dieses rezept bekommen habt dann geht
aufs tennis - block der etr steht noch
mal alles ganz genau für euch das ist
jetzt natürlich sehr große menge falls
jetzt nicht 16 iuga blätter ausrollen
wollt dann macht einfach die hälfte das
reicht auf jeden fall auch und dann
bekommt ihr auf jeden fall 68 davon also
ich glaub maximum drei personen das flex
und drei personen na ja 3 bier das
reicht für drei personen aber ich habe
drei bleche drei personen oder 1 murat
also dann würde ich ganz viel spaß beim
nachhaken
ich werde bestimmt auch noch mal eine
alternative zeigen auch mit einer
anderen füllung mal und wir sehen uns
dann beim nächsten mal
hackfleisch schnellecke kartoffel ist
lecker kämpfen noch gesprochen
vielleicht bist du mir die trams gemüse
aber schweiz so lecker blick ganz vieles
immer gespannt auf deine türkisches koch
oder backen